this tweet over the weekend
this tweet over the weekend i've really
been looking forward to getting into
this everybody piled on this dummy
so this guy is named uh kyle kalinski
yeah he actually debated uh charlie kirk
yeah debated charlie kirk and he's been
on rogan i believe he's also an idiot
he's he's a lefty podcaster uh he has um
700 000 subscribers on youtube although
his videos only regularly get 60 000
views which to me is always weird
he tweeted this out this weekend he
lives in new york by the way
uh this land by colorado and the kansas
border
this this is the land by colorado and
kansas border from a plane
pretty cool i have no idea how or why it
looks like this
so you look it's literally just a
picture of farms
when you look at the picture it's
it's just farmland if you've ever flown
in this country you've
you've seen you you've seen
farmland um well let's let me just
because you know
you want to make your [ __ ] and he
wasn't joking by the way because he
doubled down
this wasn't a bit he wasn't joking let's
stop being all high for luton and
pretending like
everybody's flown not everybody's flown
in an airplane
if you've ever even played sim city
exactly
then you know what a farm looks like if
you've ever seen a superman movie
when they do the establishing shot oh my
god that's
do you think that he's so dumb that
they're he's watching a show like that
he was watching like smallville and he's
like
oh that must be krypton it must be just
like a series of boxes
so he he doubled down on it by this is
i mean he was getting bombarded right
like dude delete your account like it
was really bad
and i gotta give mark dice because mark
dice had a really really good tweet
mark dice got a picture of this of new
york skyline and he goes
hey i'm flying on a plane what do you
think these huge buildings joining out
from the ground are
i've never seen him before he says
i never fly this is what uh kyle
kolinsky says
i never fly and i think variations of
color in the picture is beautiful
sorry my wonderment isn't sufficiently
cultured or edgy
no you got caught being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] condom
and you know it's easy to laugh at it
obviously it's really easy to laugh at
it
but even more than that to me
it shows you it shows you when when
when we criticize or people criticize
the
the
the all the lefties that think their
entire world is what happens in new york
or san francisco
or by the water and we go these people
don't give a [ __ ] about people in the
midwest
this guy doesn't know where his food
comes from like
you know what i mean like that's that's
weird to me and
look we live in florida okay but even
living we have
farms in florida like we see this like
you see it you can see those on the
ground
and get an idea where they would like
and i look i don't fly often you've been
you've flown from new york to california
at least once if you were on rogan right
so if you've flown over this land before
they don't
this is the exact reason why people go
it should be one vote for one person it
shouldn't be
because the midwest would be left to rot
that's what would happen it would be
left
to rot yes and nobody would care about
them
it wouldn't matter they don't care they
don't care about you
none of these people care about you
unless you live by the [ __ ] ocean
they don't give a [ __ ] about you these
lefties and by the way if you really
want to get into this guy's
this guy's politics if you really do you
should check out his pin tweet
incomplete list of policies dems can and
should pursue
medicare for all living wage plus right
to union
free colleges and the wars public
financing of elections
no corporate pac money no big money
building uh
bundling pledges body cams on lobbyist
green new deal new deal so this guy's
just
retire yes and the these are the guys
who have these podcasts
and and the pod save americas and all
these people none of them
none of these people give a [ __ ] about
you
none of them none of them care they are
establishment
lefties they live in their little bubble
and all they know about politics is what
happens in brooklyn
yeah look at those people down there man
they must be living like animals in
those little squares
yeah it's crazy disgusting [ __ ]
people i have no respect for
who i tell who i who i tell them who to
vote for and how to think [ __ ] losers
and if not i call them racist yeah it's
just it's great it's great when these
idiots
get caught called out like that